[موسيقى]
ايطاليا
في الواقع الرد الروسي اتى مفاجاه للبعث
خاصه بعد اشارات الغرب وحديثه عن تقارب
صيني روسي وحتى الى ابعد من ذلك بان الصين
تساعد وتسلح روسيا وطلبت حتى الصين بابراز
دلائل على انها لا تفعل ذلك يعني هناك
حديث عن تقارب صيني روسي ولكن حينما طرحت
الصين مبادره لوقف اطلاق النار وكان روسيا
رفضتها هل هي مناوره ام رفض حقيقي لشروط
شكرا لك على هذه الاستضافه تحيه لك الكريم
اعتقد المبادره اقرب الى الجو الروسي الى
الشروط الروسيه منها للشروط الاوكرانيه
على نحو واضح لكنه اصبح صعبا على روسيا ان
توافق على هذه المبادره بعد ان رفضها
الغرب عمليا رفضتها الولايات المتحده
والتعاطت معها اوكرانيا بدبلوماسيه عاليه
لكن ليس بجديه الشرط الاهم الذي تقبله
روسيا بالتاكيد في هذه المبادره هو تعليق
العقوبات الاقتصاديه
ولا يطلب منها المبادره الانسحاب الى
الحدود الدوليه
بمعنى هي لا تلبي مطلبا اساسيا غربيا
واوكرانيا المبادره ميته حقيقه ولدت ميته
فيها الكثير من العموميه لا دخول في
التفاصيل الا بخصوص
العقوبات ايقاف العقوبات ضد روسيا
واعتقد انه الرفض الغربي لها
تماما واوكرانيا لم تقم بوارد
قبول بهذه المبادره لانها تمنح المزيد من
القوه حقيقه والنفوز لروسيا فكان طبيعيا
ان
ترفض روسيا بعد الرفض الغربي هذه المبادره
سيده البعض يقول بان روسيا تحاول رفع سقف
مطالبها بهذه التصريحات بهذه اللغه لما
تقول بان الوضع او المرحله غير ملائمه
لفتح مجال للسلام ولوقف اطلاق النار
وكانها تريد ان تقول باننا بقونا على هذه
الحاله باقون على سيطرتنا على هذه المناطق
ويمكن ان نناقش ما ابعد من ذلك او مرحله
اخرى
كيف تفكر روسيا
اولا مبادره صينيه ما كانت مره الاولى
الدول الاجنبيه تحاول ان يعالجوا موضوع
هل على عسكري سياسي اليوم في منطقه
اوكرانيا لماذا حاولت تركيا حاولت دول
عربيه حتى الان وزير الخارجيه مملكه
العربيه السعوديه موجود في كييف وكذلك دول
اخرى
حاولوا ان يكونوا وسيطا لا يستطيع ان
يحصل على
رفض الروسي روسيا كانت مع مفاوضات والحاله
السياسي يوم التالي بعد ادخال قواتها
المسلحه الى اوكرانيا وروسيا كانت تلاحظ
كل المبادرات الاجنبيه لحل مشكله موجوده
حاليا
شروط الروس يه
رفضت الروسي اي اقتراحات بما فيها
اقتراحات الصينيه لان السن حليف استراتيجي
للروسيا لذلك لا يمكن نحن نعارضه او
نكافحه موقف صيني هذا النص نفس التفسير
كانت للصين الشعبيه لوان الذي كان بزياره
ويلتقي مع بوتين معروف
الامن القومي
كمال جميل اعطوا الي صوره كامله تابعوا
هناك فوارق فرق بين رويه
صينيه على معرض في اوكرانيا ورويه روسيه
اي فرق ان السينا شعبيه تعاني من مشاكل
ناتجه من تدهور اقتصاد الاوروبي واقتصاد
الروبي الناتج من الحرب الاوكرانيه طبعا
في اقرب الوقت ان يضعوا الحظ على هذا
ولكن
حضرتك تقول بان روسيا بهذه التصريحات
الراهب ولكن
باحترام الامن القومي الروسي اذا اقتراحات
مناسبه نحن نرحب ولكن بدات العمليه عسكريا
نتيجه
شكوك في ضمانات الامريكيه لامن القومي
الروسي رساله
هل الموضوع يتعلق بضمانات امريكيه ضيف
يقول على عكس ما حضرتك تفضلت به ان تقول
بانه روسيا اطلقت رصاصه الرحمه على هذه
المبادره هو يقوم بانها بالعكس هي ترحب
بها وهذه التصريحات هي تصريحات لمحاوله
دراسه هذه المبادره لا اكثر فهل الموضوع
متعلق بطرف ثالث بواسطه بضمانات امريكيه
يعني الضمانات التي تطلبها روسيا وتسميها
ضمانات امنيه هي ضمانات متوسعه غير منطقيه
تنقض حقوق الدول الصغيره المجاوره لروسيا
المرتعبه من روسيا ونتحدث هنا عن جورجيا
عن اوكرانيا عن
تعبئه البدء بموضوع الضمانات الامنيه
الروسيه اعتقد امريكيا ميت يفهم امريكيا
على انه هذه محاوله روسيه لفرض هيمنتها
على
المناطق شرق اوروبا هذا اولا بخصوص
المبادره انا اعتقد لا طرف اخذ هذه
المبادره بجديه
بسبب عدم امكانيه تطبيقها هي تدعو الى
امرين وقف اطلاق النار يعني هناك 12 نقطه
العمليات النقاط العمليه فيها هما اثنان
وقف اطلاق النار
ورفع العقوبات الاقتصاديه انا اعتقد ترحب
برفع العقوبات الاقتصاديه عليها لكن وقف
اطلاق النار ليس من مصلحه اوكرانيا وليس
من مصلحه الغرب اللذان يشعران انهما في
اطار تحقيق انتصار بطيء يعني زياده
المساعدات العسكريه الى اوكرانيا
اسلحه الان تقترب من ان تكون فتاكه الى
اخره فوقف اطلاق النار الان سيعطي لروسيا
المزيد من الوقت للتهيئ والاستعداد
مستفيده من رفع العقوبات الاقتصاديه التي
يعني تقترحها المبادره اعتقد هذان الامران
يعني كان كافيين لقتل المبادره لكن لا طرف
من الطرفين يريد ان يخسر الصين مبادره
عامه فيها الكثير من الحديث عن القانون
الدولي اوكرانيا لا تريد ان تخسر الصين
وتدفعها اكثر نحو روسيا وروسيا ايضا لا
تريد ان تخسر الصين لانه الصين يمكن ان
تساعدها على كسر العقوبات الاقتصاديه
ويمكن ان تزودها ببعض الاسلحه ببعض
الاعتدة رغم الرقابه الغربيه بها
والتحضيرات الغربيه بهذا الخصوص وبالتالي
يا سيد الا ترى كضيفي بان هذه الضمانات
التي تطلبها الجهه الروسيه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي في نهايه الامر
تعجيز هناك وكان محاوله لافشال هذه
المبادره وهذا ما حصل
لا ليست هكذا لان روسيا تنزل على كل
الجهود لواء اطلاق النار
وتنقل الى الى حل السياسي
للحوار لازم ان يكون ليست من السلطه
اوكرانيه لان بريه بري الروسي صوت
اوكرانيه ليست مستقله باتخاذ القرارات اي
قرارات
مرتبطه قرار مفتاح قرار هو في زياد واشنطن
ولذلك كل مفاوضات مع كيف كما بينت هذا في
شهر ابريل الماضي عندما كانت الظروف
اتفقوا
وجواب على اي نوع من الروادات قبله هزيمه
العسكريه روسيه
من المستحيل ان ترفع ان ترفع عقوباتها على
روسيا وروسيا لا زالت تمسك بالاراضي
الاوكرانيه
اولا انه ليست
ان الروسيا طلبت من امريكا ان لا تحاول
اوكرانيا الى مصدر
تخريب الامن القومي الروسي وهذا كان في
ديسمبر 21
رفضت امريكا وهذا هو السبب لبدعه عمليه
عسكريه وهي يجري حديث انواك وعمليه عسكريه
يجب ان نرجع الى رساله بوتين الى بايدن في
شهر ديسمبر 2021
هذا الملف سيبقى للمتابع اود شكرا جزيل
الشكر
دبلوماسيون السابق ومن واشنطن الدكتور
عقيل عباس الخبير في شؤونه السياسيه شكرا
على المشاركه
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]